speaking of verbal fans Murray the 100
caused quite a stir this season and
there was a lot of business going on and
in the middle of all this is your
character Octavia developing what we
found to be in the finale her actual
killer instinct what was the fan
reaction when Octavia killed pike I mean
based on Octavia's reaction when the
Romeo and Juliet romance came to an end
and Lincoln got executed and shot in the
head by Pike Octavia's heart smashed
into a million pieces since she had to
watch but she had to suck back her tears
because at the end of the day Octavia is
a warrior and you don't cry until the
war is over and she was hungry for
something and that was ultimately
revenge yeah and how do you think that's
going to play out when you guys come
back well based on the way the season
finale went and after Octavia straight
up murdered him uh it was supposed to be
a band-aid for her broken heart and
ultimately that didn't band-aid the
wound at all and you're gonna have to
see what happens in season 4 when she
becomes an assassin and things get
darker damn alright and uh are you still
tooling around la on the Harley I just
bought another Harley and now I have a
purple one too
I have to yeah so what do fans what our
fans like when they see you riding
around in a Harley I can't hear them my
motors loud
Murray do you even get to watch TV
you guys are like always out in the
woods away no cell phone service er and
uh yeah so pretty much yeah I'm just
excited that I get to spend a couple
days here this time and not be in and
out like lake trout back to northern
Canada so I'm gonna walk around the
floor tomorrow and check out your
costumes hmm oh and Venus open so the
100 especially has an incredible fan art
Friday situation like and it seems to
like go through the whole week now have
you gotten any artwork that you keep and
have framed or anything like that um I
do actually there's a lot of drawings
that come in
and I'm really inspired by everyone
someone just recently got an Octavia
tattoo on their arm whoa take it easy
that's there forever
nice who was it was it like no no Eliza
it was me yeah you any kind of weird
run-ins awkward I just did a birthday
trip to appeal it islands in the
Philippines which I didn't even know
existed it was like a hundred people on
this island I got nailed by a jellyfish
on my toe went to like the first aid
tent and the woman told me in broken
English there's just like are you
Octavia from that show I'm like yes so
that was unexpected and random that she
fix my foot it certainly grateful
you